a good evening
my name is Charles Mooney I am a
professor of law at the University of
Pennsylvania law school and I had the
pleasure tonight to introduce my friend
and colleague David Seale David as you
know we'll be discussing tonight his
recent book debts Dominion the history
of American bankruptcy law
David is graduate of the University of
North Carolina as well as the University
of Virginia School of Law where he
served as an editor of the Law Review
following law school David Steele
clerked for judge Stapleton on the US
Court of Appeals for the Third Circuit
and then practice law right here in
Philadelphia with the firm of Dwayne
Morris and Heckscher specializing in
bankruptcy law David left practice to
accept an appointment with the Temple
University School of Law while David was
a temple he established himself as a
nationally recognized legal scholar and
two areas of law corporate law and
bankruptcy law I was delighted that in
1999 David joined the University of
Pennsylvania Law School faculty temples
loss was Penn's gain but I think we
should all be quite happy that David
remains here in Philadelphia where he
contributes so much to the community
actually David publishes not only legal
scholarship but he's a poet as well and
for many years David has been several
years he's been an elder at the tenth
Presbyterian Church nearby in Center
City so without further delay I would
like you to welcome my colleague David
Seale
thanks Chuck for that nice introduction
and thank all of y'all for coming the
reference to poetry made me think that I
was I thought about bringing bringing a
poem that I've written about bankruptcy
just in case things get really slow but
I will spare you that and I also want to
mention I want to thank everyone for
coming there are folks from all
different walks of my life in life
generally I want to particularly note
that Henry summer is here who is the
leading consumer interest consumer
bankruptcy lawyer in the country has
been for the last 20 years so if there
are any hard consumer bankruptcy
questions or even any easy ones I'm
going to quickly turn them around in a
few minutes and try to draw on Henry's
expertise and we have a number of quite
prominent bankruptcy lawyers here as
well what I'd like to do for the next 10
or 15 or maybe 20 minutes is three
things or it gets four things really
quickly first I want to talk just for a
minute about how I came to write this
books or in the background of this book
and and what caused me to develop this
interest and put it into book form
second I am actually for a couple
minutes actually going to read from the
book which is not something one does too
often read from books about bankruptcy
history but you will be here if nothing
else of permanent importance goes on you
will be one of the few among the few
people have ever listened to a reading
of a book about bankruptcy history and
then third I'm going to talk very
briefly about some current events that
we're all familiar with and how both how
the book relates to them and and casts I
hope at least a little bit of light on
them and fourth I will open up for what
I hope will be a lots of questions and
spirited conversation so first how did I
come to write the book well I went to
law school as Chuck was alluding to a
moment ago many years ago now as an
English major we have no interest in
business courses at all and the way I
first got interested in bankruptcy was
by taking a bankruptcy class that I took
for one reason
one reason was that the professor who
taught it was a fabulously gifted
professor and I had basically adopted
the policy that where he led I would
follow even into an area like bankruptcy
and in the course of the the class I he
not only lived up to expectations but he
persuaded me that bankruptcy was and he
was both very important and quite
interesting I learned a number of things
in the course of the semester one is
that the fight to enact or whether to
enact a federal bankruptcy law at at the
early in the early years of the nation
was seen as one of the most important
battles in our early history there was a
a pitched battle between folks like
Alexander Hamilton who thought we needed
a federal bankruptcy law if we were
gonna have any kind of a commercial
society on the other side there were
folks like Thomas Jefferson who were
worried about the effects of a
bankruptcy law for in a sense in a sense
for exactly the opposite reason
Jefferson was interested in promoting an
agrarian society and he was worried that
a federal bankruptcy law would undermine
that so I learned a little bit about the
history and that there was a time when
actually people care deeply about
bankruptcy law I learned as well that
the immediate prior bankruptcy law the
bankruptcy law that was passed in the
1930s had a somewhat similar pedigree it
was largely drafted at least on the
corporate side by William Douglas who
was an advisor to Franklin D Roosevelt
and later became a Supreme Court justice
the longest-serving Supreme Court
justice in history he had drafted the
prior law and that seemed kind of
interesting but most importantly I think
what struck me was the realization that
our bankruptcy laws are different from
any bankruptcy laws in the world they
just look completely distinct from the
approach to insolvency that you see
almost anywhere else really anywhere
else so that's changing a little bit
right now and if you had to summarize
what it is that makes our bankruptcy law
so different it is that they are much
more sympathetic to fresh starts second
chances reorganizing things of that sort
our bankruptcy laws both for consumers
and for corporations are laws that
promote a second chance or a fresh start
very different from the much more
hostile bankruptcy laws that you see
elsewhere in the world so what I set out
to do in this book was try to explain
why that is why is a political matter we
ended up with bankruptcy laws that look
so different from bankruptcy laws
everywhere else in the world and I'll in
a minute I'll read a little bit from the
book and give you a flavor of the
argument I develop in the book but I
wanted to mention as well that there
were as is always the case I suppose a
number of kind of interesting side
detours in the course of researching
this book one is I learned a lot more
about Huey Long than I had ever known
before for those of you who don't know
who Huey Long is he was a senator from
Louisiana the subject of all the king's
men which if you've never read it you
should read it it's a fabulous book
figures very prominently in the
bankruptcy dates of the 1930s I also
learned that the hostility to lawyers
that we lawyers experienced now is not a
new development I was reading in the
19th century congressional records and
there are not infrequent references to
what scum we lawyers are and what my
favorite evidence of that was a joke
that appears in the 1890s in the
Congressional Register here is the or
the Congressional Record here's the joke
the joke is how is a lawyer like a man
who is having trouble sleeping at night
any guesses as to the connection he lies
on one side then turns over and lies on
the other so the recent lawyer jokes are
are not a new development I am sad to
say so that's the background of the book
what I'd like to do now is just read
from a little bit of it I won't
persecute you for too long but what I'd
like to do is read from the inter
dr. Chapter three or four pages and I
will annotate that a little bit and then
I'll talk about a little bit about
current events before I turn it over to
the rest of you so let me read a couple
pages from the outside of the book
bankruptcy law in the United States is
unique in the world perhaps most
startling to outsiders is that
individuals and businesses in the United
States do not seem to view bankruptcy as
the absolute last resort as an outcome
to be avoided at all costs no one wants
to wind up in bankruptcy of course but
many US debtors treat it as a means to
another healthier and not as the end
consider a few of the high-flying
visitors to the nation's bankruptcy
courts in 1987 Texaco filed for
bankruptcy at a time when it had a net
worth in the neighborhood of 25 billion
dollars we thought that was a huge
bankruptcy back in the 1980s we now know
from Enron that that's not such a big
bankruptcy after all two years earlier
Texaco had been slapped with the largest
jury verdict ever a 10.53 billion dollar
judgment to Pennzoil for interfering
with pencils in formal agreement to
purchase Getty oil when Texaco filed for
bankruptcy no one thought for a moment
that the giant oil company would be shut
down in its assets scattered to the
winds Texaco filed for bankruptcy
preemptively to halt efforts by Pennzoil
to collect on the judgment and to force
Pennzoil to negotiate a settlement the
strategy worked in Texaco emerged from
bankruptcy two years later numerous
famous and near famous individuals have
also made use of the bankruptcy laws
each year when I teach a course in
bankruptcy law as a diversion from the
more technical details I keep a running
list of celebrities who have filed for
bankruptcy Tia Carrere filed for
bankruptcy in the 1980s in an
unsuccessful effort to escape her
contract with General Hospital and join
the cast of a team which probably dates
me that I would think a team is
is a meaningful cultural reference but
for me it is Burt Reynolds Kim Basinger
and James Taylor of the musical group
cool in the gang all have filed for
bankruptcy as have Eddie Murphy and the
famous Colts quarterback Johnny Unitas
an important benefit of US law for
debtors in addition to generally
favorable treatment is control an
individual who files for bankruptcy has
the option to turn her assets over to
the court and have her obligations
immediately discharged that is voided or
to keep her assets and make payments to
her creditors under a three to five year
rehabilitation plan although neither
option is ideal the debtor is the one
who gets to choose when a business files
for bankruptcy its managers are given
analogous choices the managers determine
whether to file for liquidation or
reorganization and if they opt for
reorganization the managers are the only
party who can propose a reorganization
plan for at least the first four months
of the case in addition to the benefits
for debtors a second distinctive
characteristic of u.s. bankruptcy law is
the central role of lawyers in most
other countries bankruptcy is an
administrative process decisions are
made by an administrator or other
official in debtors often are not
represented by counsel in the United
States by contrast bankruptcy debtors
almost always hire a lawyer as do
creditors in the bankruptcy process and
unfolds before a bankruptcy judge in the
United States bankruptcy is pervasively
judicial and character the contrast with
England is particularly revealing like
the United States England has a market
based economy with vibrant capital
markets and a wide range of private
sources of credit the two nations also
share close historical ties when the
first u.s. bankruptcy law was enacted in
1800 for instance Congress borrowed
nearly the entire legislation from
England despite the similarities between
the two countries however their
bankruptcy laws now look remarkably
different when an individual debtor
files for bankruptcy in England
she faces close scrutiny from an
official receiver generally without the
benefit of counsel the official receiver
rather than the debtor is the one who
determines the debtors treatment and
debtors are rarely given an immediate
discharge far more often the court at
the recommendation of the official
receiver temporarily delays the
discharge or requires the debtor to make
additional payments to her creditors as
with individuals the managers of English
businesses lose control if the firm
files for bankruptcy creditors and their
representative the trustee takeover and
bankrupt firms are usually liquidated
although English bankruptcy cases do
take place before a judge as in the
United States
the process is pervasively
administrative in character accountants
rather than lawyers are the leading
private bankruptcy professionals in
England for anyone with even the
faintest interest in u.s. bankruptcy law
its distinctive features raise a
question that cries out for an answer
how did we get here
why does US bankruptcy law look so
different from the approach in other
countries although a great deal has been
written about the u.s. bankruptcy law no
one nowhere in the literature can one
find a complete account of the political
factors that produced modern American
bankruptcy law over the course of the
last century and I go on to say how this
book tries to do that a couple more
pages and I'll stop reading the
distinctive features of US bankruptcy
law date back to the final decades of
the 19th century the book focuses most
extensively on the hundred or so years
from that era to the present but the
tone for the debates that would fill the
19th century congressional records was
first set in the earliest years of the
Republic in the late 18th century
bankruptcy lay at the heart of an
ideological struggle over the future of
the nation Alexander Hamilton and other
Federalists believed that commerce was
the key to America's future as one
historian has recounted bankruptcy was
central to the federalist vision both to
protect non-fraudulent debtor
and creditors and to encourage the
speculative extension of credit that
fueled commercial growth on this view
bankruptcy assured that creditors would
have access to and share equally in the
assets of an insolvent debtor and it
facilitated the pattern of failure and
renewal that was necessary to a
market-based economy in sharp contrast
to the Federalists Jeffersonian
Republicans called for a more agrarian
future and questioned whether the United
States was ready for a federal
bankruptcy law is commerce so much the
basis of the existence of the US as to
call for a bankrupt law Jefferson asked
in nineteen in 1792 on the contrary are
we not almost entirely agricultural
Jeffersonian Republicans feared that a
federal bankruptcy law would jeopardize
farmers property and shift power away
from the states and into the federal
courts these general concerns would
continue to animate lawmakers debates
throughout the 19th century the sympathy
of commercial interests and hostility of
farmers endured as did their shared view
that one's position on bankruptcy had
enormous implications for the US economy
as a whole by the end of the century the
debates over bankruptcy in the battle as
to whether silver or gold should be the
basis for monetary exchange were treated
as flipped sides of the same coin for
agrarian populist spoke the proposed
bankruptcy legislation and restrictions
on the use of silver were anathema there
have been constant efforts on the part
of the creditor class to adhere to the
single gold standard and bring down
prices senator Stewart of Nevada
complained during the hearings that led
to the 1898 act in the same creditor
class sought to regulate commerce
through federal bankruptcy legislation
as the century went on the debates
became more rather than less complicated
in addition to those who either favored
or opposed bankruptcy legislation some
lawmakers called for a bankruptcy law
that provided only for Bank for
voluntary bankruptcy that is a law that
debtors could invoke but the debtors
creditor
could not lawmakers also argued over
whether any bankruptcy law should
include corporations or limit its reach
to natural persons the debates proved
inconclusive for much of the 19th
century with Congress enacting
bankruptcy laws in 1818 41 in 1867 but
repealing each of the laws shortly after
its enactment not until 1898 did
Congress finally enact a federal
bankruptcy law with staying power as
lawmakers wrestled over federal
bankruptcy legislation another
insolvency drama unfolded entirely
outside of Congress during the course of
the 19th century the railroads emerged
as the nation's first large-scale
corporations the early growth of the
railroads was fraught with problems due
both to over expansion into a series of
devastating depressions or panics
numerous railroads defaulted on their
obligations at times as much as 20% of
the nation's tract was held by insolvent
railroads rather than look to Congress
the railroads and their creditors
invoked the state and federal courts by
the final decades of the 19th century
the courts had developed a judicial
reorganization technically receivership
it was this technique rather than the
bankruptcy act of 1898 that became the
basis for modern corporate
reorganization rather than providing a
simple answer to our overarching
question how did we get here the early
history of u.s. bankruptcy requires us
to address a series of additional
questions why did the bankruptcy act of
1898 endure while each of the earlier
acts failed why did it take the form it
did why did large-scale reorganization
develop on a different track in the
courts rather than with Congress where I
go on from here is to develop the
political story that lies at the heart
of the book which is an argument that
federal bankruptcy law became permanent
when creditors organized when there were
nationwide organized organizations of
creditors such as merchants groups and
boards of trades
trade and that the creditors the
pressure from creditors was opposed by
countervailing pressure from populism
and other pro debt or ideological forces
and when you put those two things
together organized creditors on the one
hand populism and pro debt or sympathy
on the other hand you got a compromise
that only could get passed by enacting a
very very limited bankruptcy law with
limited procedural apparatus that
created a need for a bankruptcy bar
because it was a very minimalist
administrative apparatus and these three
forces collectively have shaped American
bankruptcy law so that we have this
these organized creditors on the one
hand Pro debt our forces populism to a
certain extent the progressives on the
other hand and then you have bankruptcy
professionals also helping to shape the
bankruptcy laws and you think of if you
think about the things that have been
going on recently the debates in
Congress over the last couple years you
see all of these forces very much still
in evidence
I'll read maybe one more page and the
night.the the 20th century discussion
and the 20th century bankruptcy reforms
have were generally preceded by
large-scale governmental investigation
so there were some investigations in the
1930s led to very major changes in the
late 1930s investigation again although
it was less of an investigation more of
a sort of a report on the state of
bankruptcy in the early nineteen
seventies led to major changes in 1978
so one we just say a page about the
investigation in the 1930s which was
spearheaded by William Douglas T the new
dealer and few in subsequent Supreme
Court justice who looked at bankruptcy
corporate bankruptcy didn't like what he
saw and drafted some legislation that
dramatically changed the face of
American bankruptcy okay so let me read
I'll read just about a page of this
it starts out this this investigation
starts out as a report of the Securities
and Exchange Commission the SEC which
had just been formed in 1934 headed by
Joseph Kennedy the father of the future
president the SEC itself was brand-new
in 1934 one of the first tasks of the
new agency was to select the person who
would oversee its protective committee
study this is a study of corporate
reorganization as the SEC and its staff
considered possible appointees they
quickly gravitated toward a single name
William Douglas and I go on to talk
about some studies that Douglas had been
involved in Douglas is extensive study
of bankruptcy filings together with his
work on corporate law and railroad
reorganization made him an obvious
choice to oversee the protective
committee study he also had impeccable
New Deal credentials as a law professor
at Columbia and now Yale Douglas knew
and worked with several key members of
Roosevelt's Brain Trust and he had been
deeply involved in the Reformers
discussions on corporate law reform from
the very beginning in an in an exchange
with brain trustor Adolph Burleigh a
Columbia University law professor
Douglas told Burleigh you can count on
me to pour pull and ore in the effort to
establish federal control over corporate
law which had long been regulated by the
states did not hurt the Douglas had been
described as the outstanding professor
of law in the nation in early 1934
commissioner James Landis contacted
Douglas on behalf of Kennedy and offered
him the post from the moment Douglas
accepted he became the administration's
point person on bankruptcy by 1937 when
he became the SEC chairman he spoke for
the administration on corporate and
financial issues generally before they
completed the investigation Douglas and
his investigators questioned many of the
leading lawyers and bankers in the
country both John John Foster Dulles the
future Secretary of State in Samuel
unter Meyer who was well known for his
role as counsel to an earlier conduct
congressional investigation were
subjected to wither
in scrutiny in connection with the
collapse of the Krugerrand toll business
empire
Douglas claimed in his at often Douglas
claimed in his often apocryphal
autobiography that Robert Swain the
prominent reorganization lawyer in
Douglas his former boss felt as though
he had been held upside down and shaken
until all of his fillings fell out after
Douglas finished his questioning to
paraphrase from the movie Casablanca
Douglas Abe Fortas and the staff were
shocked simply shocked at what their
investigation revealed like everyone
else
the reorganize errs already knew that
receivership proceedings or the the new
dealers already knew that the
receivership proceedings were dominated
by Wall Street investment bankers who
set up and ran the protective committees
used to effect a reorganization and the
bankers work together with their Wall
Street lawyers Douglas as we have seen
had personally participated in the
practice was not so much their dominance
that drew the Reformers ire though this
surely was a contributing factor as the
extent to which the bankers and lawyers
seemed to further their own interests
rather than those of their clients and
I'll stop there just as far as the
reading part and just note that there's
very interesting echoes between the
concerns that folks were worried about
in the 1930s about how Wall Street was
dominating corporate reorganization in
some recent developments in bankruptcy
where creditors have become similarly
powerful I think in in large scale
reorganization cases so let me stop with
that and I'll just for a minute talk
about current events and then I'll turn
it over to y'all my way of backdrop when
I when I first wrote this book when I
was first finishing this book I assumed
that I would have to make a big pitch to
persuade people that bankruptcy actually
mattered and I knew I was in trouble
when my son Carter came up to me and
said dad maybe if next you write about a
book about baseball someone will read it
and you could actually become famous
so I had this whole pitch lined up and
prior to to 911 the pitch had something
to do it had something to do with all of
the things I've been talking about that
the current event has seen most relevant
was the pending bankruptcy legislation
that's been bouncing around in Congress
for the last couple of years that is
designed to make bankruptcy discharge a
little bit harder on debtors it's
designed as many people probably know to
force to force more debtors in the
chapter 13 which is the bankruptcy
option that contemplates that you will
pay your creditors over time rather than
getting a discharge right away it was
nearly passed this legislation but for a
small Bowie Kuhne Burt Reynolds OJ
Simpson problem that the legislation ran
into so my question would be what do
Bowie Kuhn was at once the Commissioner
of baseball Burt Reynolds and OJ Simpson
have in common I know the bankruptcy
lawyers in here know what the answer to
that is and the answer is they all move
to Florida because Florida has an
unlimited limited homestead exemption
what homestead exemption is is a
provision that allows you to protect
assets from creditors even if you fail
to repay creditors bankruptcy honors
state law exemptions and the Florida and
Texas state law exemptions for
homesteads for your house are basically
unlimited so you can go to Florida don't
don't take this as legal advice but you
can go to Florida buy a very expensive
house and no matter how much it costs if
you can buy it with cash you can keep it
and that's what Bowie Kuhn did that's
what Burt Reynolds did that is why OJ
Simpson lives in Florida right now so
that was all part of the pitch since
9/11 things have obviously changed and I
think it's more obvious to people why
bankruptcy matters and why it's
significant to the state of our economy
I'll just mention two more current
events of relevance or let me back up
for a second but the book does talk
about the current legislation that is
proposed and talks about Henry Somers
role in that and
and also in consumer bankruptcy
generally it takes it up to the end of
last summer at which point we were all
still guessing whether it was going to
pass or not which we are all still doing
now
the second current event immediately
after 9/11 was the airline bailouts the
airline bailouts might not seem to have
a lot to do with bankruptcy but the
underlying assumption that that drives
you towards a bailout or at least I
would argue the underlying assumption is
that bankruptcy can't handle the fallout
of a catastrophe like that that it would
that we can't afford to let Airlines
fail and go through the bankruptcy
process which which I think historically
is not an accurate assumption and and
the the effect of 9/11 is is obviously
unique but there are some interesting
analogies between the crisis the
airlines faced in the crisis the
railroads faced in the 19th century and
the railroads were reorganized just fine
the third event or set of events
obviously is Enron and Anderson and it
hasn't gotten so much press yet the
Global Crossing we'll be hearing about
is hearing more about I think as soon as
people get tired of hearing about Enron
all sorts of questions that arise out of
those cases with bankruptcy implications
you know one of the the less scandal
oriented questions is what does Enron
say about the future of large-scale
corporation corporate bankruptcy in this
country putting all the scandals to one
side questions about well bankruptcy
helps or could it help save Anderson
would would bankruptcy be an attractive
strategy for Anderson Arthur Anderson at
this point in time all sorts of
questions of that sort and obviously my
case is that the book sort of provides
the background so that you too can can
answer these questions before a live
studio audience you may be right you
might be wrong but you may be crazy okay
let me stop with that and take questions
from anybody who wants to jump in in
Page
my I have a slightly nuanced view on
that I actually and Henry might disagree
with me on this one but I actually am
sympathetic to the the expressed
rationale for the legislation the
expressed rationale was to the extent
that debtors can repay something of what
they owe it's a good idea for them to do
it and and even to require them to do it
so I'm sympathetic actually to that
general concept my view of the
legislation is that it doesn't remotely
come close to achieving that I talked
about this in some detail in the book my
view of the legislation is the only real
effect it will have if it were to pass
would be to raise the cost of filing for
bankruptcy it forced you it forces you
to fill out a bunch of new documents to
show whether or not you need to be
forced into chapter 13 that's the
so-called means test part of the
legislation does a number of things that
really won't sort out debtors very well
and they'll just basically increase the
cost of bankruptcy so I'm sympathetic to
the idea I'm not sympathetic to the
legislation I think it's a bad idea the
new legislation do anything to limit the
homestead exemption it does a little bit
but not a lot and that's the fighting
that's those that's probably the biggest
fighting issue of the legislation right
now what what it originally did was
required that you live in the state for
a while before you you try to claim the
homestead exemption so it dealt with
timing and you couldn't move to Florida
the day before you filed for bankruptcy
and keep your house as big as it was I
think it was 180 days or something of
that sort since then since this issue
this issue became the most prominent
issue in the debates there have been
dollar amounts
put into the legislation I'll ask Henry
if you remember what it's 125 125
thousand max on the is actually between
the Senate which does put a hundred
$25,000 cap on the unlimited homestead
and the House bill which still does not
put any cap on the homestead and that is
one of the big fights that's going on
that's what I mean that was the major
thing that hung it off before 9/11 and
then when 9/11 hit and it was clear that
the economy was in bad shape the idea of
making bankruptcy harder at the time
when everybody lots of people were in
financial trouble struck people as as
sort of unfair or inappropriate and that
that further complicated the the case
for passing the legislation it the bill
passed both houses by fairly by pardon
partisan majorities there were pretty
much all the Republicans signed on
although with some exceptions when the
homestead issue came up most Republicans
signed up signed on a non-trivial number
of Democrats signed on and I think it's
fair to say it has become increasingly
Republican versus Democrat I mean it
started out as sort of by pardon its
partisan support for the for at least
the idea of the legislation it's become
more partisan and there was always a
question about how solid the Democratic
votes were whether these were people who
really wanted the legislation to go
through or whether these were people who
were assuming though that you know when
Clinton was in office he was going to
veto it so they didn't have to worry
about their votes and that the homestead
thing is complicated things because the
Texas and Florida senators care about
the homestead exemption I know at least
one of the Texas senators I think do you
remember Henry who there are a couple
Republican senators voted against it
right and in the Senate yeah probably
the people who were most
in favor of defending the unlimited
homestead our senator Hutchison from
Texas and Senator Brownback from Kansas
which also has an unlimited homestead
but both of the senators from Florida
and both of the senators from Texas are
very much in favor of the UH not putting
any limits on a homestead exemption and
just to turn from question answerer to
question asked or entered you have a
prediction on whether or that you want
to make on what's I mean whether it's
good it's seriously alive still the
legislation there the conference
committee is still in you know out there
and compromising on some of the issues
besides the homestead issue there's a
actually a very big issue about whether
people who basically harass abortion
clinics will be able to discharge their
liabilities in bankruptcy and that has
become a big issue between people on the
two sides of the abortion debate right
and that's a very interesting and in
lots on lots of levels frustrating
debate because it is largely symbolic
it's not clear that the abortion
provision is gonna add that much to
what's already in the Bankruptcy Code
about making debts not dischargeable but
people care a lot about the language and
exactly whether it uses the word
abortion or doesn't use the word
abortion of and things of that sort
one further note on this the whole
what's going on with the legislation and
in particular the homestead issue a lot
of people thought that Enron was would
have a big effect on the debate and that
Enron would make it absolutely
impossible for the legislation to pass
and the the reason for that is ask
yourself the question where do Ken Lay
and the Enron executives live they live
in Texas what do they have in Texas very
big houses that are worth a lot of money
Ken Lay has something like an eight
million dollar house in Houston will
some of those folks be filing for
bankruptcy in the next year
good K a pretty good chance that they
will be so the thought was that once the
public realized that that homestead
exemption was not just an abstract
concept but it was connected to an Ron
and Enron executives might be taking
advantage of the homestead exemption
that people would just not vote to pass
bankruptcy legislation that didn't deal
with that issue that didn't restrain the
homestead exemption in some way but
there's also it seems to me a kind of
odd way in which Enron could increase
the possibility of the bill passing if
it's still alive and that is that the
Enron situation the fact that lake and
lake would use the unlimited homestead
exemption makes it so outrageous not to
do something about the homestead
exemption that people like Bush who was
thought to be hostile to limitations on
the homestead exemption might cave as a
result that the that Enron might
actually weaken resistance to some sort
of monetary compromise on the homestead
exemption so it's a very sort of
complicated set of relationships between
Enron and this legislation and where it
stands now as Henry noted is it's still
in Congress versions of it have passed
both the House and the Senate there is a
conference committee it's not clear
whether it will go much further at this
point or not I appreciate your comments
you touched briefly on Anderson and I'm
wondering if you could comment a little
bit on what would be the ramifications
of an organization like Anderson that's
a limited liability partnership in
declaring bankruptcy because it's
certainly a scenario that one can
imagine and seems to me that the limited
liability partnership may be operates in
the gray area between individual
liability and corporate liability it's
not obvious that bankruptcy would help
the individual partners of of Anderson
the ones that are potentially on the
hook the ones that were involved in the
in the Enron account in some way it if
Anderson files for bankruptcy it
provides a way to deal with
with Anderson's liability but those
partners are still on the hook it does
not affect their liability and the
status of their liability is that
Anderson is a limited liability
partnership and what what that in what
that business form is intended to do is
to limit personal liability for
malpractice and things of that sort to
the partners who actually participated
in the malpractice participated in the
Enron account for instance or had
supervisory authority over someone who
did participate and it's not clear
that's what it's intended to do it's not
clear whether the folks who didn't have
any direct relationship to Enron will be
protected it's it's it's a new enough
business entity so there's still are
questions but that's that's the purpose
of the entity bankruptcy doesn't help in
any obvious way with respect to the the
individuals beyond what the corporate
forum already does when you were looking
looking at other countries bankruptcy
laws were you able to draw any
inferences about negative or positive
effects on their economies and does your
book talk about any lessons that we can
import from those countries the short
answer is no I don't get into that is
it's the focus is almost exclusively on
American bankruptcy so I do not do any
kind of cross-cultural comparison
although I am doing some work now that
I'm hoping will point in that direction
and there there is some empirical data
that tries to sort that out that tries
to sort out the economic effect of
different bankruptcy systems and it
suggests that at least the data the the
couple studies that I've seen that the
American system does turn out to be more
effective however you define that that
effectiveness but there all sorts of
difficulties and in reaching that kind
of a conclusion and there's a lot of
debate exact about exactly what the
studies really do show but it is
I mean it's an important issue and it's
certainly one that is quite relevant now
because the current trend in bankruptcy
laws is in an American kind of direction
although our our laws are very different
from the laws everywhere else in Europe
in particular there is a movement in an
American's direction in this in a number
of respects the main one being that a
number of companies have adopted
reorganization provisions that look
somewhat like ours although they're
still fairly different as well how have
the wars in American history and
militarization of the economy affected
the debate or the direction of the
bankruptcy laws that's an interesting
question I'm not sure if I know how to
answer it it's much easier to answer
hipster question so you changed the
question it's much easier to answer the
question how have have economic changes
and economic problems affected the
bankruptcy laws and and the easy answer
to that is how would you predict in the
19th century when we would have a
federal bankruptcy law and when we
wouldn't the two predictors were did we
just have a depression or an economic
panic and are the Republicans in power
if those two things come together you
get a bankruptcy law when those two
things go apart the bankruptcy law
disappears and you know even in the 20th
century when bankruptcy federal
bankruptcy became permanent there still
was a direct causal relationship between
serious economic problems and bankruptcy
changes as far as Wars you know I I
don't have any intuition I mean you know
wars economically tend to lead to
inflation I don't know you know I don't
know what you know it may be on the
consumer side you get more bankruptcy in
the wake of a war because of the
disruption does anybody have an
intuition about that I really don't have
an intuition between about the
connection between war as war separated
from
from the state of the economy at the
time of the war and bankruptcy anybody
else see I've got a very similar
question though great rather than than
war technology and changing products
there are a lot of parallels between the
late 19th century and railroads and
infrastructure with Airlines and
transportation and bandwidth and
spectrum allocation and that sort of
thing but there are some things that are
that are fundamentally different like
the you know exotic energy swaps that
were the the staple of Enron two
different products different
technologies changed as I've been struck
by everything is political and it
doesn't change it doesn't just the
forces shaping this all the sculpting
forces don't seem to have technology in
there at all
well it clearly technological changes
have a critical effect in it you can
probably map those onto bankruptcy in a
number of different ways they tend to
lead to disruption I mean when there's a
massive when there's a dramatic change
in technology you know you have shifts
and industries and and you probably you
know on the whole get get more
bankruptcies as a result but the Fisher
if this is is directly tied to
technology but but one important aspect
of our traditional bankruptcy approach
to bankruptcy with with corporations is
it works best with firms that have hard
assets I mean the railroads with a
classic example assets that aren't going
to go anywhere that are right there
where if you can just stop everything
and Rio and you get all the creditors to
the bargain bargaining table you can
restructure and come out in better shape
and that was true with the railroads
it's true with the airlines even now
it's not true with a company like Enron
and with a lot of the companies that are
filing for bankruptcy now and that
forces very real changes in the approach
to bankruptcy in a case like Enron to
some extent global
saying the assets walk out the door at
the end of the day and and it's not a
situation where you have two years to
sort of model around and come up with a
plan you've got to do things upfront so
what happens is you have you're much
more likely to have sales of major
assets in a new economy kind of
bankruptcy everything happens on a much
shorter timeline that very frequently
most of the bankruptcy case is mapped
out before you ever file for bankruptcy
so to use a for instance although Enron
is maybe not a great example in this
area and Ron's energy trading business
which was 90% of its its of its revenues
that was sold within a couple weeks of
bankruptcy to to a bank and everybody
knew it had to be sold right away
because a company with a business like
that that depends on credibility the
ability to make good on contracts can't
keep that business together so you're
gonna have to sell it so the effective
technology is I think disruption and
dislocation which does tend to to
correlate with bankruptcy and
technological changes that move us away
from hard assets really changed the look
of bankruptcy cases and we're definitely
seeing that right now current chapter 11
cases for the most part Kmart's and
exception came out as a more traditional
case but current new economy kinds of
cases they just proceed in a very
different way and they proceed much more
quickly saying that if the railroads
pulled through the airlines could have
pulled through can you give sort of a
narration of what
in the wake of the 11th absent the
airline Bailey I think what would have
happened is that several of the airlines
would have filed for bankruptcy in the
wake of the of 9/11 and one of them is
near and dear to many of us right here
in Philadelphia US air was not in great
shape then it's not in great shape now
without the bailout there's a decent
chance they file for bankruptcy and you
know my argument that bankruptcy can
handle it is an argument that you know
maybe that's not a bad thing you know
maybe a failing airline oughta file for
bankruptcy if it is worth keeping
together it will get reorganized in
bankruptcy and the real advantage of
bankruptcy it seems to me is you end up
with a an airline buy airline
determination of whether we ought to
save this firm or not the problem with
with bailouts as bailouts are
indiscriminate for the most part they
tend to try to save everyone although
this particular bailout is a little more
nuanced than that but bailouts usually
try to save everyone whether they're
worth saving or not and they also the
possibility of bailouts creates terrible
incentives if you're an airline and you
know that you're going to be bailed out
you know you're too big to fail it's
gonna affect the way you deal with the
possibility of future risk that said
there is one argument for bailouts it
seems to me even as I've become
increasingly a sort of pro bankruptcy
advocate is the solution to most kinds
of problems the one argument for
bailouts it seems to me is if the
problem is a short-term problem you know
if 9/11 is an immediate cash crunch it
doesn't reflect any long-term problems
with the airlines it's just a cash
crunch bailouts may be less costly than
bankruptcy bankruptcy does cost money
and it does take time and if if all you
need to do is solve a short-term cash
problem there's a case for a bailout but
otherwise I think bailouts are bad idea
and it's not clear to me that the
airline bailout was useful but we've
still got those problems there we've
still got us air and one or two of the
other airlines that may well be filing
for bankruptcy in the next couple of
years and and I just don't think bailout
solve that problem
he is a basic business strategy from the
start and creating companies I mean look
at the dot-com Fiasco I'm not sure
exactly how to take to take that quick
you can take the bankruptcy is strategy
question in a lot of different ways I
think bankruptcy can be used
strategically but that's that's more
after the fact I think then when the
time you you start up the argument that
a lot of people are making now which
which is an argument about the overlap
between consumer bankruptcy individuals
following for bankruptcy and small
businesses which sounds like corporate
is that bankruptcy plays a critical role
in an entrepreneurial economy I mean if
if you have an economy that assumes that
some ideas are gonna work and some ideas
are not going to work and that you want
to to promote ideas and the possibility
of the ones that fail failing and then
starting again bankruptcy makes sense
and and it turns out that that is true
with respect to consumer bankruptcy or
at least there's an argument it is that
since many small businesses are at heart
individuals who are using their credit
cards to finance the business if you
tighten up on bankruptcy you might be if
you tighten up too much on bankruptcy
one effect might be to to chill
entrepreneurial behavior a little bit so
that's one kind of strategic aspect of
it do you have others in mind I mean
there's this people spend the owner
limits the aggressive marketing well
that's a balance I mean that's obviously
a downside of bankruptcy is is that if
if it's easy to discharge your
obligations you're obviously gonna look
at your credit cards a little bit
differently than if it's tough to
discharge them and I think that's part
of why there's an argument for requiring
people who can repay to repay at least
at least some of what they owe
but it's it's pretty clear that if if
bankruptcy is easy that's gonna affect
the way you look at credit it's also
true that part of people's willingness
to take on a lot of credit is tied up
with the change in the nature of credit
for the last hundred years you know a
hundred years ago you wouldn't have
gotten a credit card application in the
mail or five of them or six of them
every week you would have had if you
wanted to borrow money it would have
required a face-to-face transaction with
a lending officer and you know it may it
may be it shouldn't make a difference
but I think people just look at the
obligation differently if it's something
that came in the mail as opposed to
something that involved driving to the
bank and talking with a lending officer
yeah I don't think it changes your point
but I think that is all part of this
complicated debate about you know is is
there a decline in stigma and people's
willingness to to file for bankruptcy
and not worry about it on the one hand
but on the other hand credit card
companies don't exactly have clean hands
either so it's you know it's a sort of
it's a complicated debate I think hmm
with the Penn Central bankruptcy unique
or just a routine business bankruptcy it
certainly was not a routine business
bankruptcy and in fact I talked about
the Penn Central bankruptcy at the
beginning of I think the last chapter of
the book a lot of people Penn Central
the Penn Central bankruptcy was a big
bankruptcy here it was big big
bankruptcy everywhere but it had it was
here in Philadelphia and so it obviously
had a huge effect here a lot of
bankruptcy lawyers see that as one of
the cases that signaled the real
transformation of bankruptcy love
corporate bankruptcy law in America and
for a long time corporate bankruptcy law
was it was a you know the percentage of
reorganizations was not all that high it
was not it was not the sort of thing
that large law firms were involved in
regularly through the 60s that began to
change and Penn Central is seen by a lot
of people as is the case when modern
corporate bankruptcy practice came of
age I mean it was Wall Street firms were
involved in Penn Central all of the big
Philadelphia firms were involved in Penn
Central it was a huge case it went on
for a long time it was one of the first
cases where there was buying and selling
of claims in bankruptcy what's referred
to as claims trading where creditors
would there'd be a market for creditors
selling their claims which is a relative
recent development that seems to have
started a tour around the Penn Central
case so it was a hugely important case
it was in some respects similar to a lot
of the cases that came after it but it
was very different from the cases that
had come before it so it was it was at a
very distinctive case or questions if
you can sir that's all right but just
change the question that's why I was
just wondering about the kind of more
recent rise in multinational aspects of
corporations how does that interact with
our own laws how do they if has there
been a case where one has had to a truly
multinational corporation has had to
declare bankruptcy and how does that
work in the different countries that
it's based in well I'm happy to say that
is something I say at least a little bit
about in the book I have a short segment
in the end that scene is one of the big
contemporary corporate bankruptcy issues
what do you do when you have a firm that
is not just a US firm it's a US and UK
firm and a Japanese firm as well there
are a lot of open issues on that there
been a couple really big cases that have
sort of tested that the biggest one one
of the biggest ones was Maxwell
Communications which was both a UK and a
US firm and the big debate both in the
literature and in policymaking circles
is whether to use what's referred to it
as a Universalist approach or to use
what's referred to as a territorial
approach a Universalist approach says if
you've got a company that's in a lot of
different countries what we should do is
pick one country system whichever is the
most appropriate system either because
most of the assets are there the
headquarters are there and use those
laws to govern everything the
territorial approach says each country's
laws should apply to the assets in that
particular country you can probably
imagine
the way it has tended to play out
historically countries are not usually
that anxious to say well you know it's a
Japanese company that has assets here
we'll use your laws Japan
what has tended to happen is as a
practical matter the approach has been
territorial that each country has dealt
with under its bankruptcy laws the
assets in that country there is a
movement now in the other direction most
commentators think that the the most the
most effective approach would be to
somehow come up with a set of laws that
you could apply across the board and
there are there are some treaties that
are being negotiated that have been
negotiated or are being negotiated now
that are designed to move us in that
direction I think that's where we're
headed one of the things that will make
that a little bit more plausible is that
there on the corporate bankruptcy side
in particular there is a bit of a
convergence in bankruptcy laws Germany's
bankruptcy laws they don't look quite
like ours but they look a lot more like
ours than they did 20 years ago or even
15 years ago so that as bankruptcy laws
start to look more similar I think
you'll see more of a willingness to use
one set of laws across the board and
when you don't do that when you when
it's a nation by nation kind of thing
you can imagine the conflicts that arise
they rise all over the place
Alec's looking at me skeptically as you
often do okay a debt owed by Enron to
Deutsche Bank how do you do what how do
you locate the Deutsche Bank asset and
the Enron liability for example that
would exist in an Enron loan from
Deutsche Bank I'm not sure if I'm
completely in this content area the
first question would be yeah well
presumably its bankruptcy I mean it's um
it's an Ron's bankruptcy that we would
be talking about so that if you used a
universalist kind of an approach you
would use US laws and you would apply US
laws to to this obligation that is owed
or which direction you have it going
into to Deutsche Bank but I think
there's a problem in here that you're
worried if I'm a tea is that
yeah that depending on how you do your
hypothetical that when we get to Germany
somebody with assets in Germany is going
to refuse to turn them over to an
American Court is that the kind of you
said each country's law will apply to
the assets located in that country well
where is that debt located oh you do
that's another kind of question you're
assuming an approach that takes a
country-by-country approach to to the
assets in the case with traditional
assets that's pretty easy if the asset
is a house that's wherever the house is
with new economy assets it becomes a lot
more complicated where where is a
licensing agreement or where is some
sort of copyright which may be a very
valuable asset and all I'll say about
that is that's a hard question but as we
say on law school exams it's a hard
question that does not admit of an easy
answer but it presumably I mean what you
would have to do is come up with some
sort of standard for how for how we
determine it mean you can imagine you
know a standard that you would you would
come up with to deal with most
intangible assets but that is an issue
for like Arthur Andersen to not only do
the accounting but also to do the
consulting for large firm when the
health of the firm is determined by the
accountants well the concern about about
Arthur Andersen and other accountants
having an interest both on the auditing
side and on the consulting side the
concern is that if you care a lot about
the consulting and it turns out that's
usually the case ordinarily the
accounting fee the auditing fees that an
accounting firm gets from a company are
much less than the consulting fees in
any given year the concern is that if
you're worried about those consulting
fees you Arthur Andersen or whoever it
is are going to be a little bit less
aggressive aggressive about your
auditing than you would otherwise be and
in the in the Andersen Enron case it
turns out that Anders
audit fees and its consulting fees we're
roughly comparable it was in the twenty
five million dollar a year range on both
sides but there still is that issue the
concern is if Arthur Andersen
aggressively audits Enron who is Enron
going to use when it's looking for
consulting services for an acquisition
or whatever
probably not Arthur Andersen is the
concern and that's the perceived
conflict of interest I think it is a
very real conflict of interest
I personally to make two evaluations my
company that's right and that's why
there's a lot of talk now about forcing
a separation between the auditing arms
and and the consulting arms and and the
proposals bouncing around right now take
a variety of forms the most draconian of
them is a proposal that would prohibit a
firm that does auditing from also doing
consulting which I personally think is a
bad idea but the arm it's designed to
get at that potential conflict credit
card debt and whether you avoid credit
card debt do you think that there are
certain areas are the certain things at
the bankruptcy law deals with that other
other areas of the law or other
regulatory agency should be dealing with
or how are I mean should it seems like
the credit card issue could be more
effectively dealt with via the bank
regulators and maybe limiting you know
they're over solicitation I think that
is quite that's quite plausible and I'm
gonna turn it back to Henry in a second
but there has been Henry gives me this
look every time I got I this is a plea
for help
there's been a lot of discussion about
that in connection with the bankruptcy
legislation as well about building in
and it actually there have been some
proposed provisions that are part of the
legislation that would do things like
require additional disclosure of exactly
what's going on with your credit card
there is an argument that we should use
banking regulation or beefed up the
existing Truth in Lending type
regulation to get at that problem of
over solicitation so yeah I think the
answer is yes and in fact there was a
lot of there has been a lot of disco
in the Legislative debates about the
idea that well if we're gonna make
bankruptcy tougher um so we're going to
deal with the concern that debtors are
filing for bankruptcy too quickly we
ought to deal also with the other side
of the problem and do something about
over solicitation and lack of screening
by the credit card companies of the
folks they give credit card carts to
Henry do you have you actually were
involved in some of this earlier
legislation there were quite a few
people in Congress who said we ought to
do something about that for example
there was a proposal to tell people on
their bill if you make the minimum
payment it's going to take you thirty
five years to pay off your credit card
needless to say the credit card
companies didn't like that and that
didn't find its way into the bill but
there is no doubt that the increase in
bankruptcy is mainly related to the
increase in credit availability and
especially to the high interest and
predatory lending that targets poor
people who are often unable to pay back
those debts I I do have to disagree with
one thing you said David roots I don't
really think there are a lot of people
who go out and incur credit card debt
thinking I can file bankruptcy if I
can't pay this I think they incur it
because there's advertising because it's
pushed on them because their neighbors
buy things because people are
advertising things that they want to buy
and the typical the vast vast majority
of people who file can pay their debts
until something happens in their lives
that makes them unable to sort of
following up on the on the regular
regulatory side of it Henry um do you
think the disclosure kinds of approaches
would help I mean disclosing how long
it's going to take if you're paying the
minimum amount each month would would
that make a difference do you think in
in people's prohibit extension of credit
who to people who were already over
their heads in debt but those really
didn't get very far at all that would
probably make more of a difference there
also are
to clamp down on predatory mortgage
lending one of the other things this
bankruptcy bill would do would be make
it much harder for people to save their
homes from foreclosure and there were
provisions and there are still
provisions that they're going to be
arguing about in the conference
committee to clamp down somewhat on
predatory mortgage lending which is
targeted
lavash neighborhoods in Philadelphia and
it caused enormous numbers of
foreclosures other questions any current
event that we haven't yet yet that we
can solve all right call it quits Thanks
to everyone for coming I really
appreciate
David Steele is a law professor at the
University of Pennsylvania his book is
debts Dominion a history of bankruptcy
law in America it's published by
Princeton University Press online at PU
P Princeton dot e-d-u
48 hours of nonfiction books on TV
you're watching book TV on c-span -
ahead on book TV a look at some of the
financial success stories in rushes
change from communism to capitalism then
a discussion on a collection of essays
by leading Holocaust scholars tomorrow
on book TV hellenic studies professor
andre